the 2022 Nobel Prize for chemistry has
been announced
it's quite exciting
and also removes the pressure from all
the other chemists who thought they
might win it and haven't did you think
you were going to win it no
they were as usual three winners they
were awarded the prize for so-called
click chemistry and a variation of it
which is called
bio-orthogonal chemistry in Click
chemistry you take two spring-loaded
molecules and you react them with each
other very very efficiently without
generating any waste it's a little bit
like taking a safety belt in your car
and just clicking the two bits together
so that's how how efficient and and
great these reactions were there are no
traditional demonstrations of Click
chemistry
and our students Chris a PhD student
working with my colleague Neil Thomas
has devised especially for you a new
click chemistry demonstration
um so we're going to be doing a click
reaction today and this is a particular
type click correction or special type of
Click reaction and the azide we're using
will actually only fluoresce once the
click reaction has actually proceeded
the three winners were Carolyn bertozzi
who's in America Morton meldale in
Denmark and Barry sharpless who is also
in America barrier sharplist is really
quite special because he's only the
second person ever to win the Nobel
Prize for chemistry twice initially I'm
just going to add into this tube here
the copper sulfate so this is going to
be our Catalyst for the reaction click
chemistry is an area of organ organic
chemistry it is slightly ill-defined but
what it is is a way of doing chemical
reactions very efficiently and very
rapidly because it means you can even do
these reactions in water which for us
climate chemists is often very very
difficult because water is is quite
reactive itself so you can do these
reactions in water they're very
efficient you get very good reaction
outcomes and as I said you you generate
no waste which is great because we're
interested in sustainable sustainable
reactions that don't generate a lot of
waste
so he's 1.25 microliters into there
organic chemists
often construct the most beautiful
molecules by a whole series of reactions
which are quite slow the reactions and
between each reaction you have to purify
everything because each step just produ
may produce a mixture of products and
you have to separate the one you want so
in this experiment we're just using the
unnatural amino acid homo propagile
glycine
have to write that down for me yes it's
usually just abbreviated to hpg so
battery sharpless's idea was perhaps one
could do reactions more like nature
where they went real in the blue fast in
water because nature does most of its
chemistry in water reactions which would
produce just one product rather than a
mixture and so the key to this was to
find
reactions that between molecules that
have quite a lot of stored energy you
can imagine the bits like a compressed
spring and they release the energy
and the first problem was to find
suitable pairs of molecules that would
react that had this stalled energy
and both sharpless and meldal
independently discovered that you could
use so-called azides and then now we're
going to be adding the azide and this
azide probe was developed by the betosi
group
and as I said earlier this is a
fluorogenic probe that will only
fluoresce once the reaction has preceded
so you have a carbon atom here and the
azide group is three nitrogen atoms
joined together
and this is very reactive
azides are used in detonators for
explosives things like that
and they discovered that if you used a
copper catalyst you could get reactions
to go very well it is not the usual
copper the copper two plus like copper
sulfate
but it is copper one
which is not very soluble in water
but these reactions go very well in
water and there's a whole range of them
we're then going to add 7.5 microliters
of this compound called thpta which is
just going to act as a copper
accelerating ligand so it is a chelating
ligand it's just a Telltale sign really
if you're doing kind of these reactions
in a living system for example or you
want to test the um
uh yeah test the reaction completion in
ways for example in my research I might
use this to test whether a reaction has
gone to completion when I can't use
standard chemical analytical techniques
such as NMR Mass Spec and things like
that Carolyn bertozi was particularly
interested in biological systems if
you've been watching for a long time you
will have seen a 2008 Nobel Prize video
talked about the green fluorescent
protein which can be used to label
organisms
the problem is what bertozi did was to
find a way of using the click chemistry
to join fluorescent molecules to the
outside of cells the problem with
sharpless is chemistry was that the
copper catalyst could poison the
organism
you could join the molecule on but the
organism was dead so you couldn't study
Its Behavior so if you think of the
cells in our body our human cells
they're a little bit like Eminem's I
couldn't find any M M's so imagine them
like maltesers
you've got the core of your m m or
malteser and that is surrounded by a
layer of sugar
and the cells in our body look like this
as well you've got the core and then the
cell core is surrounded by a layer of
sugar and this layer of sugars is very
important in how the cell interacts with
the things around it so for example how
it recognizes friends and falls
for example our immune system recognizes
our own cells because of the sugar layer
around them and similarly pathogens that
that create disease in our body
recognize and invade cells because of
the sugar layer
so it would be really interesting for us
to find out more about the sugar layer
to understand more about the immune
system and diseases
and this is where Caroline bertozi
became really interested in Click
chemistry because she wanted to be able
to image the sugar layer around our
cells and at the time you could only do
this very destructively so imagine
taking a cell throwing it into a blender
and then looking at the bits of sugar
floating floating around in your
smoothie that obviously is very
destructive so what she wanted to do was
take chemistry take chemical tools and
be able to look at the sugar layer
around cells without destroying them
so that's all nicely mixed in there and
so even though we've got all of the
ingredients as well the reagents in
there the copper is actually in the
incorrect oxidation state to actually
act as a catalyst and so I've
pre-populated this um
384 uh well plate here some have water
in and some have ascorbic acid or sodium
ascorbate and that sodium ascorbate is
going to act as the reducing agent to
reduce the oxidation state of our Copper
from copper 2 to Copper one and
therefore the catalytic M action should
be able to proceed I met Barry sharplist
once in a at a conference we had tea
together
and he produced a huge stream of ideas
some of which were really good but
others we haven't really followed up
he's an enormously inspiring character
our former colleague John Moses who has
done videos early on in periodic videos
on aspirin for example is now a
professor of Click chemistry and used to
work with Barry sharpless so we've got
um 10 microliters so in some of these
Wells we've got 10 microliters of water
already and in some of them we've got 10
microliters of a solution of ascorbic
acid so I'm just going to fill up the
wells with another 30 microliters this
is a
really nice example of excellent
chemistry but chemistry which is useful
to humanity because it accelerates the
rate at which organic chemists can
potentially discover new medicines new
pharmaceutical products
and so it is really in the spirit of the
Nobel Prize which is to do science for
the benefit of humanity so this is just
a UV light box and this is just going to
um we're going to put it under long wave
radiation and it's just going to shine
ultraviolet light onto the top of the
well plate
so obviously in the wells I've populated
with the Sodium ascorbate conveniently
spell the word click and the ones that
I've just populated with water obviously
don't catalyze the reaction and
therefore um don't fluoresce so yeah so
the good thing is I can actually spell
yeah
this is supervisor Neil Thomas uses
click chemistry to activate spider's
silk you know the fibers that are made
by spiders what Neil does is to activate
the surface of the spider's silk to put
on either fluorescent probes or to put
on drug molecules so that it can be used
for wound treatment
and he's produced some really nice
examples of fluorescent
spider silk and he sent me some nice
pictures Caroline batozi is only the
eighth woman to win the Nobel Prize in
chemistry and as far as I'm aware she's
the first member of the LGBT community
to to win a Nobel Prize in chemistry and
this is obviously very important for
representation she explains herself that
as an undergraduate and PhD student she
faced ridicule and sometimes even
exclusion because of sexism and
homophobia so it's really important to
to have a strong role model to to
inspire and support the community and
raise awareness for for some of these
issues so bertozi also discovered that
the molecule cyclooctane
this is an alkene in an eight-membered
ring is so strained has such a lot of
energy that it can do click chemistry
without the copper catalyst and she also
coined this phrase
bioconjugate chemistry
which is now very widely used there are
even journals of it so she's created a
whole new field of chemistry I think the
Nobel Prize definitely is still still a
big deal
um
it is very inspirational to see
how far you can get with your research
especially finding applications for your
research and in a way in in the sciences
and in chemistry Nobel Prize winners are
a little bit like Superstars
very selfless
in 1970 that's more than 50 years ago
had the serious lab accident when a
glass tube exploded in front of him and
he wasn't wearing safety glasses
and he lost the sight of one eye
and ever since he has said
there is absolutely no excuse
for not wearing safety glasses in the
lab
so if there is one message that you get
from this video
wear safety glasses in the lab and if
you're not convinced watch our video
where Neil shows the way safety glasses
are important
in my pocket
I've got this
and this is a real Nobel Prize medal
it's a real Nobel Prize medal made of
gold